another day digging through the mud
and debris
another body found
the death toll has been rising since
Sunday when unusually heavy rainfall
hits several coastal towns just 200
kilometers away from Brazil's largest
city Sao Paulo nearly 50 people so far
confirmed killed by the floods and
landslides many of them in the beach
resort of Baja dosai during the carnival
celebrations
has spent two days looking for his son
and daughter-in-law with little hope of
finding them alive
most of my son's next door neighbors did
not survive their bodies were dragged
down the hill
neighbors have been working alongside
firemen in the Army Rodrigo Japan a
volunteer fireman for the past 14 years
has witnessed other major tragedies
this terrain is harder to get to we're
expecting more rain in the coming days
which means that we'll have to start
from scratch digging in the same spot
again but if the sun comes out it won't
get much better dry mud is more
difficult to clear away
these aerial images show the size of the
devastation in an area visited by
thousands of tourists especially at this
time of the year
rescue teams have been concentrating
their efforts on this hill because there
were many families living here earlier
this morning dogs were sniffing the mud
indicating that they would find more
bodies under the mud and Rubble nataira
Sakira lives further down the hill and
has been helping to identify the bodies
of her neighbors she says these ruins
were once the home of a family of four
all were killed including eight-year-old
Maria who had just celebrated her
birthday and had been saving coins in
this tiny red safety box to buy herself
a treat
I cannot find the words to describe the
pain we're all feeling
has been isolated since the floods
landslides blocked all roads making it
impossible to leave by land their only
way out is by sea nearby towns have sent
tourists and fishing boats to help many
flee but also to take much needed
supplies to the thousands who have lost
all and have stayed behind to search for
the dozens still missing Monica yanakev
al-jazeera badusai Brazil